[Music]
[Music]
what do you think this is all about i
don't know he never tells us anything
morning boys so a few of you have raised
concerns over our lack of eye care
coverage and trust me i get it when
pelpy has assured me that we will be
revamping our stormtrooper benefits
program hell yeah brother you get 20 20
vision you get 20 20 vision everybody
gets
here we come
i got
huh scallywags
so it's civilized
[Music]
can we just leave this party
[Music]
oh my a droid only bathroom are there
instructions here
[Music]
hey bro check this out
noscopes
[Music]
uh come on where are you stupid furball
hey check it out there it is
my dead
[Music]
nice headshots bro
i can spot that lip bookie from a mile
away
oh jeez how are we going to tell him
that all of his friends are dead relax
he is waking up well luke this is
awkward but you are our only hope
seriously
they're all dead
geez this rebellion's useless
ah careful that's my lightsaber hand
it's just you and our two left and those
two rookie pilots over there these two
rookies
well i guess it's just us three against
the empire is it cool our two rides on
my x-wing
okay this is red leader this is red
komodo standing by red scarlet's
standing by just stick with me and stay
in formation we're gonna be fine quick
question uh i heard there's a tiny guy
inside of r2d2 any chance i'll be able
to meet him
[Music]
oh watch out for those stormtroopers you
can't shake them they're on my six this
is nothing like the simulations
don't worry the force is on
that's a good trick
[Music]
oh [ __ ] that's like it's just me and r2
and you too luke all right the trench is
coming up you can count on me luke
yeah be advised we have rebel fighters
in the trenches
these stormtroopers are ruining
everything
only one rebel left
luke
use the force shut up the old womp rat
you're dead
i'm almost there i'm going to launch my
target three two
oh yeah
wow okay so we won
uh honestly happened a lot faster than i
expected so uh yeah set blasters to fun
blue looks on me
hey it's me luke skywalker and i'm here
to rescue you from bad content you can
head over to corridordigital.com and
check out our exclusive videos and
extended episodes of react we also have
15 off all merch and you get uploads a
day early without ads we also have
original shows like son of a dungeon and
local zero coming soon peace